[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
two
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
out
[Music]
[Music]
two
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to gamespot's coverage
of cyberpunk's night city wire episode
2.
uh we're very excited for this we're
going to go over what we saw last time
what tomorrow and i played
and what we hope to see today the show
starts at 9 30 though uh so we're gonna
fill this time
chat about what we expect but joining me
today
is timur hussein hi
and jean-luc psyche hello
all right so we do know a bit about what
this night city wire is supposed to be
they tweeted
last week i believe that for episode 2
they're going to cover
life paths they're going to cover the
weapons we'll be using and
samurai the band in the game which is
played by
the swedish hardcore band refused uh but
before we get into that tomorrow you and
i had the chance to
play some cyberpunk about a couple
months ago and we both chose different
life paths
you chose the street street kid path do
you want to tell us a little bit about
what you saw
yeah so i guess for people who might not
know what a life path
is being slightly reductive it's
effectively a
origin story for your character kind of
reminded me of dragon age origins
and a couple of the other bioware titles
but it's basically set up
for your character where they begin so i
picked the street kid path
which is pretty much what you can
imagine
like the street kids are very very
familiar with night city they
have some kind of um they are embedded
in the underground and the seedier part
of night city
so they're very familiar with you know
the ins and outs of the underworld and
you know have their own biases and
already start
are super cool with you know killing and
doing
wet work and taking on corporals and
that kind of stuff
um so yeah i picked uh the street kid
path and my character began in kind of
like this
bar where you're trying to help out um
someone else and
and kind of steal this car which you're
seeing on screen currently
um and uh that effectively this car i
believe
it belongs to an arasaka employee and
it's a super high-end car that you're
trying to steal
and um it turns out there's someone else
also trying to steal it and
here he is uh young jackie so this is
how their kind of um v jackie
relationship
begins in the game if you pick the
street kid path
what i liked about the street kill path
was you could use your
understanding of night city and your
history there to kind of intimidate
people who aren't from there
um and kind of assert your dominance
it's kind of like when you roll into
someone else's hood and they're like yo
you're not from here what you're doing
here you should
watch what you're saying where you walk
um and that kind of manifested in the
bar where i was
where uh one of the um people that i was
speaking to was giving me a mission
and was being a bit too um braggadocious
and perhaps not respecting
me or night city and it was just kind of
a throwaway line that was kind of like
you better watch what you say
you're new in town you're not from here
whereas i am and i can make things
happen
so it kind of like took took the the
power dynamic in that conversation and
switched it up a bit which i really
enjoyed
so i'm interested in them excited to see
how that street park
street kid path manifests in other ways
but at the
at the very least baseline it's a
familiarity with the city and a kind of
confidence in moving around the
social um circles of the city
yeah and one thing to clarify here is
that we saw so so
timur myself and edmund tran played each
played this and we each chose different
uh life paths and we only played like
the first two hours so depending on what
life path you choose
the sort of i guess prologue chapter you
could say will be
will be not slightly different very
different so for example i picked the
nomad path
and with the nomad path you actually
start outside of night city and i
believe what's called the badlands
and basically normally nomads roll with
like a gang
but you are a lone wolf type it's clear
that you kind of
i don't know recently had a falling out
with whatever gang you're a part of
and now you picked up a job to smuggle
something into night city
uh and it this is where it starts off in
this garage you're seeing right here
you're fixing up this old junker
uh but after this you basically meet up
with jackie as well
uh and so the gist of it is that jackie
plays a
different type of jackie i guess
depending on which origin story you pick
but no matter which origin story you
pick
jackie will still be a key character at
least for the opening hours i don't know
if anyone
i'm sure you guys all saw that trailer
but in that cinematic trailer they
released i think last e3 he actually
died in it so i'm curious to see
what the deal is with that like maybe
that was based off a decision you can
make
uh or if that was just kind of to get
people i don't know to show the
brutality of this world
um but once you meet with jackie uh
there's a package that you need to
smuggle into night city and there's
actually this pretty cool like border
crossing scene where you show up you
pull your car up
uh and they ask you to step outside and
they want to interview you and you go
inside this
this uh a border office and you get
interviewed by this
you know cybered up dude with like
glowing eyes and and he's got all these
cybernetic enhancements on his arms and
whatnot
and you can bribe him if you want and i
chose to bribe him
and he let me through and as i started
to drive through of course i think they
were arasaka
corpse like set up a roadblock and then
there was just like this
this big firefight leading in uh you
actually do open
the the case to see what you're
smuggling i won't spoil it
uh i'm sure other places have spoiled it
because a lot of people saw it but i
thought it was a
a cool little thing uh but then the
other path we have is the corporate path
um which is something that i didn't
personally get to see neither did
tomorrow
uh but you know you can kind of put the
pieces together there you
start out as a corpo and you
pretty much lose everything uh and you
can see kind of the opening here as well
uh jean-luc though you didn't have a
chance to play it
however you're very excited for
cyberpunk i was curious what path
what life path are you leaning towards
uh i was initially thinking i'd go with
nomad because it's the most
your your character is like outside of
night city so i feel like it's a good
introduction
your character can kind of like it gives
your character an excuse to like not
know what's going on
and be unfamiliar with the world as
opposed to like a
a street rat it would feel a little more
like oh i should know
like what the city's like but i don't
because it's my first time playing
that said i might end up going actually
with corpo
just because you are a um a corpo
for arasaka who seems to be a major
player in the story so i feel like that
has the most potential for story
ramifications later down the line
as far as like the cause and effect of
the origin story like playing out
later in the game like i can see a
situation where um
because the main point of the game is
that you're you're trying to
steal a piece of prototype tech from
arasaka in sort of like the first
prologue chapter of the game so i could
see you knowing people in arasaka and
that leading to
alternate paths in that main quest i
think that could be really interesting
totally i'm i'm super excited to see
what the the corporate path has
uh but speaking of which timur do you
have any predictions on
how these life paths could change the
game or
or maybe just like different mechanics
because so far we know that there are
different dialogue options
and there is a different prologue but i
was curious if you had any predictions
as to how the game could change
i'm not sure if i want to kind of
predict it mainly because
cd projekt red they're pretty good at
doing the unexpected with things that
you think you should know how they work
like they you know they turn they like
to turn things upside down
and also because given the kind of how
open the dnd kind of
or the tabletop version of this is is um
it could be literally anything it could
be anything it could be nothing
and i would hope that they'd make uh the
the effort to make both of those
interesting i think the thing that i'm
more interested in is how the world
around you changes in in response to you
um in terms of gameplay i'm sure it
manifests in kind of like
the kind of weapons that you're able to
use or or how you spec your kind of
character
um it probably is easier if you lean
into the you know street kid
or no math kind of trees or the i um
abilities that are
complementary to that but what i want to
know is like how do
characters react to you and how how do
you start to wield
that that background to your favor um
you know
in in the in the uh opening to the
street kid path i mentioned earlier that
you know you can assert your dominance
or your authority
or your street cred over people who
might not be able to
do the same and and kind of put that
into your confidence as you move around
the city
that's really cool i hope there's more
of that and then during the demos that
they show off that you know you have
these moments where
um when you're going to pick up that
prototype weapon you can choose to
either go straight to the
kind of layer of the the enemy and and
try and negotiate or you can meet up
with the corporal lady and get
get kind of like embroiled in a spy game
of sorts
which means if you are already a
corporal how does that change
that that kind of dynamic when you've
got this you know
she in in in the uh when she's talking
to a nomad or a street kid part she's
kind of like
um condescending and looks down upon you
and treats you like crap and as a tool
and does that change if you roll up and
you're actually an arasaka corporal
who knows like that's the thing that i'm
most interested in about the world
is and how that responds to your life
path is probably more intriguing to me
than the actual mechanical side of it
i do think that there will be kind of
these like key moments where
your background will um kind of derail
or re
re-root the story in big ways um
i don't know how if that means like
they're gonna kill off you know major
characters like it could jackie
be killed off halfway through the
corporal path because it's revealed you
know
that he's got some sort of cd background
that it doesn't drive with you who knows
i'd love to see that kind of stuff but
yeah the world is what intrigues me more
and how it reacts to you
yeah i'm kind of curious to see because
there's like pretty obvious benefits to
picking the street kid path obviously
you're familiar with
night city itself and there's benefits
to picking the corporate path you're
familiar with
how how corporations work but i'm
curious to see what the benefits are of
the note mad because based on what i
played like yeah there were different
uh dialogue options i could pick being a
nomad but
like there's not like an obvious uh
bonus at least inside the city that
comes to my head now i imagine
when you are exploring the badlands
there might be more to it
um but but i'm i'm curious to see how
that nomad path works out and john lucci
actually brought up something really
interesting about how
you start out as an arasaka employee and
arasaka
seems to be a major villain uh
do you want to expand on that at all
maybe even like touch on
what you kind of hope happens or how
different these paths could be
uh yeah i mean so i guess like
to not to spoil it too much but i i i
made a video where i kind of like put
together like the pieces of
the plot and it's the at least the
opening of the game
is based around the idea that you're
like trying to steal a piece of
prototype tech from arasaka so
i feel like naturally as i kind of
mentioned earlier the the corpo path has
the most
potential to be interesting with that
where
you can like oh i know somebody on the
inside who can help us get in
um but then i'm curious yeah like i'm
super curious how the other paths could
could affect it i mean like you know the
street kid
uh like are there connections that you
have
uh that you could use to like smuggle
yourself in like an alternate way like i
really
i'm so curious how that heist is gonna
pull off because uh
heists are like to me the maybe some of
my favorite like
video games like uh video game scenarios
like how are you going to pull it off
like i want this like ocean's 11 like
are you and jackie gonna like dress up
as like delivery boys and like sneak
into like
garage or are you gonna like pretend to
be like
if you you know i could see like oh i'm
a corporal so we'll pretend to be
businessmen who are making a deal and
we're going to walk in with like fancy
suits
or you know maybe like as a nomad you're
like ah screwed i don't know anything
about this city
let's just go in guns blazing i'm
i can see myself like making a hard save
and then just like
loading that specific mission over and
over again i get the feeling i'm gonna
do that a lot in this game
is like just keep reloading saves and
trying these stuff over and over again
yeah me too i i imagine that'll happen
with a lot of people because it happened
a lot in the witcher 3
uh and this seems like even more
branching than the witcher 3.
uh but moving on another big thing that
uh city project red planes i'm talking
about today
are the weapons uh we've seen
a good amount of weapons in the in the
different um
showcases and whatnot but tomorrow when
you actually played what were some
weapons you used and was there anything
that really stood out to you
so uh i i picked the most
boring way to play the game probably for
a lot of people
were talking about weapons but um so i
was playing primarily stealth like i
wanted to see
how much i could because i love stealth
games they if i get the option to be
quiet and sneaky i will almost always
take it
so i did a lot of pistols i have i had a
silence pistol
and i think i had a silenced rifle at
one point as well so it was a lot of
like um
getting into melee range and taking
anyone out that i could quietly
but then using kind of the the silence
pistol to take out anyone else wherever
possible
um that stuff felt good i think across
the board the
guns felt good and they felt distinct it
kind of reminded me i think i said this
in
my previous kind of reminded me of
destiny i'm not saying they feel as good
as destiny
but everything kind of had a punch to it
and it had a sound to it that felt
like it was good feedback um which is
tricky to do when the game you're
playing um as
as is the case for destiny 2 when you
shoot someone you know numbers fly off
of them instead of they just drop them
you hit them but everything felt good i
did reach a couple of points where my
i wasn't paying close enough attention
to what i was doing and i got caught by
something and it would erupt into
straight up uh violence and in that
scenario i did grab a shotgun
and my main approach was to kind of use
the dashing abilities the
maneuverability that v has
to kind of get around obstacles and in
enemies faces really quickly so they
can't dodge any of my shotgun pellets
and i'm
up close for like super um damaging
melee combat
um but yeah i i was mainly a pistol and
a stealth person
until i got close or until i needed to
pull out my weapons and start using a
shotgun at that point
however i did see a couple you know in
in the um demonstration the high
frequency blade
um was used a couple times and
unfortunately i didn't get my hands on
it in that demo but
that's one i'm super excited about i
hope they do lean into the futuristic
cyber tech stuff and use that a bit more
um everything that i we touched in the
in the game play that we had was kind of
like
cool looking guns based on stuff that we
already know
exists i'm interested to see if they
delve a bit more deeper and lean into
the futuristic stuff
i want some perfect dark style like
shoot through the walls
guns yeah it's it's funny you mentioned
that too because i was about to point
out that
the demo we played was very early it was
like the first couple hours of the game
so i feel like
we didn't really get to mess around with
like super cool tech
like i had a pistol which shot like a
pistol
uh i had a submachine gun that shot like
a submachine gun
one thing interesting though that i did
manage to pick up was a lead pipe
uh which sounds really dumb it's not
exciting at all but i just thought it
was kind of cool that
it is like you know that kind of rpg
where i can pick up a lead pipe and just
start hitting people with a lead pipe
um uh but kind of to your point too
tomorrow one thing that
uh we saw in i think last year's
gameplay presentation was they
were there were those like cyber wire
whip things that like melted people
and they hit them and i'm really excited
to use that kind of stuff and like
katanas
and whatnot i'm curious to see how all
that comes into play
um i guess to kind of dive a little bit
more into the weapons we might see
jean-luc you and i have been doing a
lore series where we've been looking at
a bunch of the lore from this game and
trying to make videos out of it
uh but there are a lot of weapons i was
wondering uh
if you i i don't know maybe had any
predictions or insight into uh
weapons we might see or weapons you'd
like to see oh
man i actually i haven't dived too deep
into the
the weapons of the the laureate um i
kind of been focusing more on like
characters and stuff but i i think
for me i'm most curious about melee
weapons
and just like how that's gonna work you
mentioned
you know like you we see here the the
blades that you can pull out of your
arms you mentioned
katanas and stuff i wanna know uh what
like an all melee
playthrough would look like like if
that's even possible
and i'm just curious like how if they'll
get real weird with it
um because yeah as you mentioned like i
kind of want to see like
weird weird weapons not only with guns
but also with like
melee like how weird and futuristic can
you get
with like uh like a katana or something
like
what's a what's a futuristic katana look
like in the world of cyberpunk
so then i guess to kind of jump off that
i'm gonna throw it back to you jean-luc
on your first playthrough what kind of
build do you plan on playing do you
think you're gonna do this melee
experimentation build or do you have
like an idea
of what you're gonna do well any game
that offers me
uh a like dialogue focused path is
usually what i go down so i'll always
try and put all my points in dialogue
i'll always try and talk my way out of a
situation
i i might try and and start with a melee
build and see how that goes i'm
depending on how the game works i might
have to pivot
uh if it's not viable for all scenarios
but i i think i'm going to mainly try
talking my way out of most situations if
i can
and then honestly i'm just gonna pick
like whatever weapon
seems cool like like i want to try like
weird futuristic weapons like we've seen
a little bit of that stuff there's
there's like um uh i forget what it's
called but it's like it's like a weapon
where
it like the tracer darts like they kind
of like can circle around objects and
like hit people like i just want to try
a little bit of every weird weapon they
have like i imagine my
my build in my first playthrough is
gonna be a mess because i'm just gonna
pick whatever looks cool and sounds
interesting and it's probably
actually gonna be like a horrible build
that like nobody should play and i might
have to
respec nice
uh timur you love being stealthy
you love doing non-lethal lethal
gameplay and whatnot
is that what you plan on doing for your
first play through this game
yeah that's pretty much what because i
was doing it in my demo
and the developer was like oh you're
gonna have a rough time doing it here in
this situation because it was like
like that were backed up into a corner
and and like very clear sight lines
and i managed to do it in that room and
to the point where
the developer was like you managed to
make that happen
but that was not how it's supposed like
i wedge myself in between an enemy and
like
a wall that looks like a spot that no
one could be able to get in
i like just edged in close enough to
grab the person
and the developer was like you know what
maybe we'll just move him forward a bit
so you can actually do this naturally
without
putting in that much work and then he
kind of like updated and said like yeah
there's
you can't get through most of this game
without killing um
so usually i when i play pacifist runs
like the gameplay kind of enables it um
whether that's through tranquilizer
darts or all that kind of thing this is
the first time i think
i'm interested in trying to play the
pacifist run through a mixture of
gameplay
in terms of like my physical actions and
also like my
dialogue options usually i don't think
too hard about
you know how whether your dialogue is
going to impact the way you
are lethal or non-lethal because games
don't usually mix that well
um or aren't designed to like have those
overlaps but this game definitely feels
like a game where you can have those
overlaps um so i think i'm gonna play
i'm gonna spec into like stealth and
also like charisma and good dialogue
options so i can talk my way out of
things and
hack wherever possible and and not you
know
resort to violence as much as possible i
just love the idea of being like this
street kid who's who's
got you know no blood on his hands and
it's just like a sneaky thief
a futuristic uh robin hood of sorts
i uh so so when i did the demo i did net
running
and i actually had a lot of fun net
running now i imagine
you'll probably dabble in net running no
matter what build you do or hacking
um and there's like a fun little mini
game that
shows up and i i don't know i don't know
if it'll get tiring after a while but
that is one thing i remember from my
demo was
like how much fun that little weird
hacking minigame
actually ended up being uh but yeah i
mean i think
i'm gonna play a very similar style to
you tomorrow i really wanna
i really wanna see how far i can go with
just hacking things
but moving on we got about 10 minutes
actually eight minutes
until we go to the uh uh night city live
or night city wire
before we do that though the last thing
that they plan on talking about at least
mentioned in the tweet
was samurai and how they how the
hardcore swedish band refused
transformed into samurai um
this is pretty cool i think it's the
first video game
i can think of that is actually having
bands play a role
in the game like sure it's still refused
playing these songs but in the game they
will be known as samurai
and they're kind of embodying samurai
and for those who don't know
samurai is johnny silverhand's band in
the lore uh so so i'm excited
to see what they end up doing with this
they've got a bunch of confirmed artists
and i think the only one that actually
has been assigned a band
as of now is uh grimes who is doing
was it lizzie lizzy lizzy wizzy lizzy
wizzy
lizzy wizzy um but i was curious john
luke have you heard
much of the samurai music that has been
released so far because there's a couple
tracks
i have i've listened to all of them and
i i love
it's like essentially what they're going
for is like that that very
like 70s 80s like
uh like post-war kind of like rebellious
rock very like anti-establishment
and i i love the idea that
in because in the world of cyberpunk at
this point like samurai the band is like
over 50 years old so it's like
essentially like classic rock
but i love that it's still this like
super relevant band and in the lore like
samurai became one of the most
influential bands in the world like i
love like uh
alternate reality fiction where like a
kind of relatively
niche genre ends up becoming like the
dominant
genre for a while in music like um i
think that's so
it's it's an interesting way to like
kind of like set the tone for the world
and and
set up like okay like this is this is
kind of like what these people grew up
listening to and this
like it kind of explains the attitudes
of the characters
um yeah i i i i it
the it's funny you can actually go like
listen all they have all the lyrics on
there and they're kind of
they're making hints to i think like um
johnny silverhand's like past and how he
used to like
uh you know being like part of the army
and stuff like that
i'm curious how that stuff is going to
like where that stuff is going to be in
the world um
like i because as you mentioned all of
the music
is supposed to be like in fiction so i
assume
it would be a lot of it would be
diegetic or like you're actually hearing
it on the radio
i wonder if you can like go like buy
music or anything i think there's a
screenshot of somebody like
selling like a vinyl record of a samurai
like can i go buy
like samurai like records like uh
like final fantasy vii remake style like
i can just go like
get new music and then like put it in my
car radio like i would love that stuff
so there there is a radio uh it's
something i messed around with a lot and
if i was
paying more attention but there was so
many things i was trying to focus on at
once
maybe i could have seen like who the
different artists were that are going to
be in the game or at least heard
uh but there's a radio so you will hear
a lot of that and i did hear
a couple samurai songs at least i think
samurai songs on the radio
um but one interesting thing that i do
want to point out is that
the the song chipping in which they
released i think at e3
last year or around that time uh the
course the chorus of that song you can
actually find in cyberpunk 2020
uh which is pretty interesting like the
lyrics there of like
i forget exactly but it's uh you can
find those original lyrics they're at
least part of it i'm sure they
changed it a little bit but i found that
uh pretty interesting
um but one thing i do want to do we've
got about four minutes left i just want
to go through the confirmed artists so
far
uh that we have we've got run the jewels
refused grimes asap rocky gazelle twin
elin ruspin uh richard richard devin
nina kravitz uh deadly hunter rap boy
tino guo uh probably mispronounced that
uh but just you know timur one last
question is there a
is there a band or artist you'd like to
see represented in this game somehow
kendrick lamar
easy um i'd love
i'd love to see some sort of kendrick
song in there this is a
huge kendrick fan but like there's a lot
of good hip-hop rap representation in
there between run the jewels
asap rocky is kind of rubbish now after
i think that
i'm going to go on my asap rocky tirade
asap rocky is only good because of
clemson
the producer after he split with clem's
casino the producer he's been absolute
trash
don't at me um but i'd love to see some
kendrick there
i'd love to see kendrick actually oh
sorry i was gonna say i'd love to see
kendrick actually
represented as a character in like a dlc
or something
because they're all supposed to be in in
universe like artists so like i don't i
imagine like run the jewels
they're not supposed to be themselves
they're supposed to be like their own
band
in the fiction so like i would love if
they like integrated like a story line
with some of these artists like i i'm
sure uh
grimes character uh lizzy wizzy is gonna
probably play major story they seem to
kind of be building her up she's the
you've seen her in in the trailer she's
the woman who's like [ __ ] out in all
chrome
and has like a big blue mohawk that's
her character
um i think she's also maybe the woman
with the
who like takes her mouth off in like and
she's like doing her makeup and her
she's like missing her mouth i think
that's the same character i don't know
she's not chrome in that one so i don't
know but i would
i would love to see some of these
characters more
like physically represented like i can
go i could go talk to the
the real life the in-universe
representation of
run the jewels or or a kendrick if they
put him in
yeah so we've only got about two and a
half minutes left so
uh uh tay in the back might just take
this away and switch over
um i'll try to time it well but yeah i
mean
run the jewels really stands out to me
because i feel like their kind of
rap is perfect for this sort of game uh
and i'm super curious to see what they
do like you're saying jean-luc i really
hope that
there is a i don't know rap duo
producing duo that you can
find and maybe do a quest for or
something like that because i think
there's so much potential to have
you know lp and uh killer mike
play characters in this game i think
that'd be really cool all right we got
we got one minute left uh last minute
any
any more hopes to see for artists like
any quick ones you can throw out there
i hope we get keanu reeves we haven't
seen keon reeves in so long like for
flash
give us some new give us any sort of
soundbite from him
anything new um just have him look at
the camera and go hey
and that's it that's fine i want to hear
keanu reeves sing
in the game yeah me too oh yeah
all right 30 seconds uh we'll be back
with a post show
uh so make sure to tune in after it ends
and we're gonna break down everything we
saw and maybe give you guys a little bit
more insight
based on what we played uh last month
but anyway
we'll see you after
[Music]
city of dream city
hello and welcome to episode two of
night city wire
this is the show from us at city project
red where we talk about
all things cyberpunk 2077.
in today's episode we're going to be
deep diving into lifepass and showing
you a brand new gameplay video
as well as having a chat to philip from
our quest team
then we're going behind the scenes and
taking a look at how refused to bringing
the band samurai to life
and then we're showing you another new
gameplay video
and having a chat pavel our senior
gameplay designer
about just some of the tools of
destruction that'll be at your disposal
in night city
so let's get started street kid nomad or
corpo
which will you pick first
[Music]
well who do we have here
grew up in haywood the whole street was
my family
neighbors helped each other out thought
nothing of it
i'm pleased to see you have not forgot
dudes
born here live here die here
childhood memories hopping buildings
running away from badges iron taste of
blood from a split left
got everybody fighting for a slice of
the street get the [ __ ] out of vista
if you keep getting jumped you find some
stronger tubers
do you want to spend the rest of your
days blasting scabs
or become a legend overnight
we have arrived the majority
ready to get your cherry popped yeah
come on
my childhood let's see
racing my bobber for the first time
through the hills
oh and uh first kiss in the middle of a
synth cornfield
we nomads choose who to make our family
a choice forges strong bonds and a
higher duty that stands solid as an old
oak
[Music]
my family's in pieces that's why i'm
headed for night city
makes you an outcast among outcasts
miss this you know camaraderie
i know i saw it in your heart the first
time you met
know what i always liked about nomads
your taste no
hunger for freedom not easy to come by
corpse got their grubby
i have those reports you asked for they
were supposed to be ready yesterday
the world's going to tear us apart when
the word gets around
the world's never going to find out
if i go down you're going down with me
no i'm not [ __ ] joking this isn't
a request fee but no way you're [ __ ]
right
you're the one who fixes other people's
[ __ ] if you work in our soccer counter
intel
you're always [ __ ]
today they got you to zero somebody
tomorrow i'll get somebody else to zero
you
what's the rules jack you want to be top
got to have some skin in the game yeah
but you're not on top it's a borough era
and you're the penelope keeps in there
work for yourself
live for yourself that's the only way
philip it is so good to see you again
it's actually been a while since i've
had a chance to interview you about
cyberpunk
so i think for today we'll start with a
question that everybody wants to know
how does the path you pick affect your
time in night city
it actually affects your time quite a
lot throughout the whole game but let's
start at the beginning because basically
our game
has three different starts depending on
your life path
as an example if you choose the street
kid life path
you have lived most of your time in
night city you know the streets you know
the gangs you know the slang you kind of
know what's going on
in the let's say lower life aspects of
the city
which can of course give you lots of
good opportunities also later on in the
game
but if you start as a nomad you actually
used to be part of a nomad clan and a
nomad family
because nomads that roam the deserts
around night city
that we call the badlands actually value
their family above anything
but for one reason or another you
actually left that family behind
and now the beginning of the game for
you will actually be
how to get into night city and how to
make a new life there
then you can also choose to actually be
a corporal and choose the corporate life
path
and that basically means that you're not
at home in the streets of night city
or in the deserts of the badlands but
actually inside the boardroom
because you roast the corporate letter
of the arasaka corporation
which basically gives you the ability to
sometimes you know read between the
lines
read people when they're trying to do
business which of course can give you
many nice opportunities later on
so this isn't just about the start of
the game can you maybe
help people understand how this
translates into the gameplay
yeah so the thing is we make cyberpunk a
real
rpg and part of that is that you can
play your character
from the start to the end and of course
you know we have these life paths
affecting the beginning of the game
but we wanted to make it so you have
your life path opportunities
throughout the whole game until the game
is over
and as an example we do that by giving
you additional options in dialogues
so i can give you one specific example
and this is
a mission where you have to steal a flat
head robot
from the maelstrom gang basically those
maelstromers
stole that flathead before from a
corporate transport
and the owner of that corporate
transport merit the stout
wants you to do something else and this
is an optional objective
and even within that objective we want
to give you some options so as an
example if you have a corporate
life path you basically know what
meredith stout is really about you can
read between the lines
and you can get some additional options
that maybe actually later
enable you to do a completely different
thing with the maelstrom gang and
if you're a nomad you know exactly some
more details about how these
maelstromers
would have even been able to steal a
robot like that from meredith stout
who's part of the very powerful militech
corporation
as a street kid we as an example don't
give you a specific
new dialogue option in that dialogue
because as a street kid you do not have
a lot of experience
dealing with higher up people like
meredith stout but we want to give you
additional options that fit your life
path very well
so later when you actually talk to the
maelstrom gang one member of the gang
offers you some illegal substance but as
a street kid you actually know what this
is about you can talk some shop with him
and that might actually make that
character like you a little bit more
so philip i do have a couple of extra
questions for you based on the video we
just saw
and the first is about nomads so the
nomad life path
this starts in a place called the
badlands is this somewhere you get to
visit
even if you don't pick nomad to start
with yes
absolutely so the thing is night city is
surrounded by this huge landscape
that we call the badlands and you can go
there whenever you want so as an example
if you actually do play the nomad life
path at the start and you are in the
badlands
you can even see night city on the
horizon and
we want to give you the option later in
the game if you want you can just take
your car
and drive out of the city you can go
there whenever you want
thing is you might not want to because
the badlands can be a pretty dangerous
place at first
because time has not been very kind to
the badlands
there have been many wars in the past
there's global warming
so most people that do live out there
don't really have another choice about
it
or are nomads that love this life and
are all about it and are very battle
hardened
we of course also want to tell their
stories because we want to tell
many many different stories throughout
the cyberpunk genre
which means that you will also find
missions that lead you out in the
badlands
or where you deal with the people living
there so philip can you tell us a little
bit more about the character padre
he's the guy we see giving his business
card to street kid v
in the video who is this man yeah so
potter is actually one of the fixers in
night city and fixers are people that
work as intermediaries
so if someone who has a lot of money
needs a problem solved they go to a
fixer
and a fixer then finds people who can
solve that problem and these people
are people like you the cyberpunks
fixers are very territorial
so padres specifically works from
haywood which is where you as a street
could grew up in so you already know him
you might have already seen another one
of our fixers who is called dexter
desean
and he works in a different part of the
city so specifically padre
you might know him as a street kid but
even if you played other life paths you
might sooner or later meet him because
he's operating in haywood which is a
pretty big place
with many good jobs so if you want to
make some cash there
you will sooner or later deal with padre
philip thank you
so much for joining us now on my first
playthrough pretty sure i'm gonna be
picking nomad
but for those watching we would love to
know what you'll be picking so have a
think about it
and send us a tweet don't forget that
later in this episode we're going to be
showing you another new gameplay video
and having a chat to pavel our senior
gameplay designer
about just some of the tools of
destruction that will be at your
disposal in night city
but before that let's talk about music
because music plays a
huge part in bringing night city to life
now in future episodes we're going to
talk about things like radio stations
and even the original score
but today we're going to take a look
behind the scenes that have refused to
bringing johnny silverhands band
samurai to life
[Music]
so it's kind of interesting to get into
like the mindset of
who is this character and what would
they write about what
what's their agenda
[Music]
it's interesting to to try to like catch
a language that
that's his and try to catch a language
that's like
a part of this game
[Applause]
there is a reason why we're here
it was piotr maybe who was a fan of the
band
he knew refused my voice and said oh
that's a perfect voice for
for johnny
and that they wanted i guess a sound
that was a bit contemporary from when
it's
when john is supposed to have had the
band because he's sort of like an
anti-establishment kind of guy gonna
drag a corporal rat on stage
make them kneel down with gaston light
them up so of course there are things
that you can relate to and like
just like this outcast and this rebel
that's fighting against like the the
corporates and
that's definitely something that's been
a part of my life and a part of refused
we came out of the punk rock scene of uh
northern sweden
he's like the future version of us
[Music]
so i i think it makes sense i think it
totally makes sense for us
to be here making these songs about him
or for him you know so it's pretty cool
yeah no no no no trails
but yeah but like white vibrato
we don't have a different mode than just
going
all in so we really work on these songs
trying to make them
as good as possible then they're not
actually
our songs it's interesting as as a
musician
to play another musician because that's
essentially what we're doing i mean
we're not here
as refused we're here samurai and i'm
here with johnny it's still around you
know so it's like the voice we're
representing here is someone else
it's been a mind [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
i mean the shouting in itself is just
like second nature to me because i've
been i've been doing this for a very
long time
but then when someone comes in and says
i'm happy with everything except for as
a limb
again it's as a as a
i think we had it earlier okay
the shouting is great but think of that
accent so think of that like enunciation
it's a bit weird because it is it's a
very different way of singing when you
when you're screaming like that and it's
hard to sort of
keep swallowing some syllables there
adjust your accent
oh yeah just try it again so it's been a
bit
frustrating it wasn't it wasn't
[Music]
it wasn't horrible but it wasn't great
but i mean i get it i mean we we have to
maintain the illusion that
this character that's a character of the
game also is
me like when i'm singing it so it makes
sense but yeah it's it's a bit
different to have someone telling you
exactly how to
announce these things because i'm not
used to usually people are just like
give me a thumbs up and then like you
know you you think the things like the
rhythm and you think about the pitch and
you think about all these things but
then someone comes in and like
that word sounded weird i'm like what no
it's how i sing but
so it's been a very uh yeah very
painful at times
it's all right see it is soon i'm
chipping in
roll the boots i'm chipping here but
that
it's a very interesting thing to be part
of
as as a person that's not a gamer i
don't think i fully understand the
impact that this might have
if people like these songs and if people
are excited
that then that's gonna be great i mean
we are spending a lot of time
trying to get this right try and get it
to sound like you know
like samurai would sound you know so
it's it's quite interesting it's a very
different way of
of making music actually
you can already find three samurai
tracks available on streaming services
chipping in never fade away and the
ballad of buck ravers
but we're excited to announce a fourth
new song
called a like supreme which is coming to
streaming services
today that means you can check it out
once the show is over
don't forget that if you're tuning in
late or if you just want to watch
anything
again we will be uploading everything to
our channel soon
next up pavel and i are going to
introduce you to some
creative ways that you can solve
problems in night city
[Music]
av i have a job for you
a client of mine is making an arms deal
he needs
protection it could get hot
very hot the gun dealers are maelstrom
alas nothing ever transpires
with them you better gear up for this
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you willing
yeah i'm in
pavel thank you so much for joining me
now there was an awful lot in that video
right because it's more than just guns
absolutely we have melee weapons we have
ranged weapons we have cyber where we
have
offensive cyberwear defensive cyber
armor
we could talk for hours and hours about
this stuff
i think just for today's episode we
should keep it simple and let's just
talk about guns
can you tell us uh the different types
of guns that will be in the game
so we have three distinct types of guns
in our game we have
power weapons we have tech weapons and
we have smart weapons
now power weapons are the most similar
to contemporary weapons
one thing they can do which normal
weapons cannot is ricochet bullets off
of surfaces
so you can hit somebody hiding behind
cover or hiding behind a wall
now tech weapons on the other hand use
electromagnetic power to propel
a fully metal projectile to extreme
velocities
what that allows them to do is to punch
through cover or punch through walls
to hit somebody who's not even aware
that you're there
smart weapons use guided missile
technology to actually track targets in
real time
so you can hit somebody who's dodging
running away from you
or you can hit somebody who's hiding
behind cover
so pavel cyberpunk doesn't just contain
fps elements like it's also a fully
fledged rpg
so can you tell us how you guys
approached introducing those rpg
elements into gunplay
so i can tell you one thing holly it
wasn't easy to merge those two elements
together
now we've spent a considerable amount of
time
merging the rpg and fpp side of our game
what the player will experience is that
v
changes from a small time mercenary to a
legend in the world of night city v
becomes
more and more proficient in using
weapons as the game progresses
so they will see that reload times
become shorter
the accuracy of your weapons grows
you will have faster aiming time you
will move faster with your weapons
everything becomes more in your control
and that gives you
more opportunities to defeat the biggest
encounters that we've designed for you
so i have prepared a few extra questions
for you pavel if you're feeling up to it
of course okay well the first is going
to be how do you find more weapons in
night city like where will players be
looking for them so i expect the players
to look
everywhere for new and exciting weapons
you can of course
buy weapons at vendor shops and they
will house
an entire catalogue of weaponry that you
can get
however the best weapons that you can
find will be taken from
enemies or loot caches that we have
everywhere in night city
the weapons rarities range from common
to uncommon up to rare and then
legendary
and as they go in rarity they actually
climb in power
however legendary weapons are very
specific
in such a way that they possess unique
abilities that you will find on no other
weapons in the game the players will
actually
need to make some tough choices to find
some legendary weapons because
maybe they need to choose whether to
kill a person
who holds the legendary weapons that
they want or
to spare them because they like them as
a character
so next question let's talk about weapon
modifications
what mods can people give to their
weapons in night city
so we have two types of modifications in
the game one of them would be
modifications that we call attachments
so these would be scopes and silencers
and you can see them
actually being attached to your weapon
as you're playing the game they give you
statistics advantage and they give you
more opportunities in gameplay
the other part of modes would be
software modes
now these are basically small chips that
you install in the
in your weapon and they actually change
the statistics of the gun
they can give you damage they can give
you accuracy or they can give you
more fire rate some of those mods
actually change the
gun play on a more fundamental level so
they can give you
non-lethal rounds biochemical rounds to
tear through that armor
even faster so i suppose for my final
question
uh why don't you tell us about your
favorite weapon then which is your
favorite weapon
so far in night city oh there are so
many weapons that it's hard to choose
just one but i can mention some
manufacturers with their weapons that i
absolutely adore the first manufacturer
would be
tsunami defense systems who produces the
sniper rifle nekomata
that's a tech sniper rifle that means
that it can pierce through walls so you
can actually hit
somebody who's hiding behind cover or
who doesn't even know you're there
of course i also like a close quarters
approach
and what that needs is a shotgun one of
the shotguns that we have in the game
is budget arms carnage now that thing is
cast from
pure steel and it weighs a ton however
you can cut a person clean in half with
it
another shotgun that i absolutely love
it's for a more refined approach i would
say
is a smart shotgun jouer that thing has
eight
barrels and that means it can track
eight targets independently
now killing an entire room was never
simpler
uh pavel thank you so much for joining
me
thank you for having me uh i'm actually
pretty interested to see what kind of
weapons people discover when they uh
play cyberpunk for themselves
before we end episode two this is a
reminder that those who wish to dive
deeper into a law
can now pick up the world of cyberpunk
2077.
this is a brand new book created in
collaboration with dark horse books that
will give you
an extensive look at what makes night
city tick before jumping into the game
this november that is it for today's
episode thank you so much for joining us
don't forget that if you've missed
anything or if you just want to watch
again we will be uploading everything to
our channels shortly
thank you so much for tuning in and
we'll be back with
night city wire episode 3 soon
all right and we are back that was
awesome
a lot of good stuff there i imagine some
people disappointed because it was kind
of sharp but
you know it was just like the first
episode they said it'll be pretty short
but
overall tomorrow what were your thoughts
on what we saw
yeah i it was a lot of uh familiar
things
so they're kind of like expanded upon
stuff that we already knew and restated
a lot of it but
um i think i got a good sense of the
mood a bit more especially in the life
path stuff particularly for the nomad
stuff which
um i'm sure one of you guys can speak to
a bit more but
um when it came to kind of like showing
off the kind of feel of the
of the world and of the game i think
this this episode did a way better job
of it than previous ones not that it's
any sort of competition between them but
like
i just got a good like sense of the
world more from this one
and also having played it it's starting
to like color in the parts of it i
left a bit black and white from you um
after playing that but yeah
um it was a good good um uh episode
uh i've got to see a bit more of keanu
which i'm happy for
um and some more like gameplay uh
information about how you can kind of
tackle situations so yeah
good stuff john luke what about you is
there anything
in particular that really stood out for
you um i definitely agree tomorrow that
the
nomads stuff was really interesting like
them talking about like being a family
and kind of like setting up that
backstory makes me
way more interested in the nomad i'm
i definitely also uh liked more the the
corpo stuff
i saw like they kind of got i got to see
more of the like what arasaka tower is i
feel like that could also be a pretty
unique one because i imagine you don't
get that much of an opportunity in the
game to like just
walk around like a corporate tower and
just like see
like the dail the day-to-day stuff of
uh like a corporation like you heard
those people like just talking about
like
you know oh we can't let this get out
you know we have to uh
and they're like oh they won't like i i
think that could be
a rather unique intro because you're
you're kind of get you kind of get to
see the inside of a corporation
um in a way you probably won't with the
rest of the game
yeah totally i mean i think i'm kind of
uh uh you know agree with you guys in
that the nomad path seems
like the most interesting uh and a lot
of what we saw in those like three
trailers
run do you guys remember like the gta 5
character trailers that kind of reminded
me of that in a sense
but i digress anyway uh it did
those trailers at least the nomad one
which i can speak to showed a lot more
than what i saw so so it seems like
these these life paths will be like
consistent throughout your story like
maybe as you're going through those two
paths the the main quest in your life
path kind of merge and you do
some quests for characters there you
hang out with some different characters
uh and and there's kind of like uh i
don't know they kind of alternate
between
um main story life path quests uh
and even like the corpose stuff that we
saw it seemed like there was a lot more
there than what
ed had explained when he played it um
yeah but it seems like for the most part
after seeing that are you guys more
inclined to pick
the nomad path to more i'll start with
you on that
yeah i think i'm having thought about a
little more especially after seeing what
they showed they're kind of like the
outsider element of being a nomad and
having your own tribe and that kind of
stuff and then moving
into night city as opposed to being a
kind of you know street kid which is
what i originally played and was leaning
towards and
always knowing night city i think that
drives with my
intended play style a bit better of
stealth and non-lethality and trying to
you know make my way through the game
without making big waves but still
quietly becoming this legendary figure
within the city that no one really knows
about because i'm not out there shooting
things up and you know causing a lot of
problems i think that kind of
vibes with me in the uh the idea of the
futuristic robin hood that i've got
like ready to role play in my mind i
love the idea of coming from this kind
of you know outsider
group and then infiltrating this wide
world of night city and climbing my way
to the top without anyone realizing i'm
really there um other than the
the few essential people who need to
know because i've come into contact with
them
um i i'm starting to lean towards more
that kind of
feeling and i also like what john luke
said before
um kind of like got stuck in my head and
i like the idea of
you know having a character that's new
to the night city in the same way that
you are so you don't feel like you've
missed a beat
by being a corporal or a street kid um
so i'm starting to lean a bit more
towards the nomad
yeah one of the interesting things too
that they talked about a little bit but
i'm curious to see how far it goes is
how
characters play different roles
depending on which life path you pick
like a key character for the street kid
path may not be a big character in the
nomad path but there's still a chance
you could meet that character
seems really interesting even to the
point where like jackie for example
is when you play street kid jackie is
like a childhood friend
while if you play nomad or sorry no if
not street kid
if you play corpo jackie is a childhood
friend well if you play nomad
you meet jackie at the beginning so i'm
curious to see
even a character like jackie who's
supposed to be a big role
i'm super curious to see how his story
changes or
dialogue changes or even like like you
were saying before the show like
maybe he just won't survive as long
in the nomad path because he doesn't
really need to be there necessarily
because your family or
your family that you've that is kind of
broken up
is out there um that being said though
uh jean-luc after now having seen those
trailers as well
are you leaning more towards nomad as
well are you still kind of thinking
corpo is the path for you uh yeah i'm
kind of in the same situation as
tomorrow where
i i think the nomad path seems way more
interesting now like that backstory
sounds like like a great way to just
like
introduce you to the world i think it's
gonna be a one a lot of people pick
because it is that like perfect
introduction to cyberpunk
that said i kind of have a sneaking
suspicion the corporate path might
have more interesting story
ramifications because
you start out as like i think i think
it's got a more interesting motivation
because you're you're um like kind of
you you lose everything
and it gives you like this really strong
reason to want to get
revenge to get back to the top and then
you have all these potential other
characters in arasaka that you would
interact with over the course of the
story
the fact that jackie is your like
childhood friend i think
would give your character uh more of a
connection to them
that would make their potential death uh
more meaningful so i'm
i'm not sure i i might end up going
corpo
because i i feel like i have a sneaking
suspicion that
it might it might later down the line
result
in some pretty interesting story
ramifications
so i'm gonna cheat i'm just gonna play
all three of them
well okay that's my answer uh but but i
think i'm with tomorrow i'm going to
start with nomad because
like he was saying that seems like a
good introduction to night city you're a
stranger as well as your character
so i think maybe after nomad it would be
good to do street kid because then you
actually kind of feel that familiarity
with the city right
um that being said all of them seem
pretty interesting though they
i feel like they definitely spent the
most time talking about nomads but
after that they talked about uh
samurai and how refused is kind of
taking on this role as
samurai and johnny silverhand but i
think
i thought that section was super
interesting but i think the biggest
takeaway from that section is something
you pointed out john luke
uh which we think might have something
to do with braindance but do you want to
elaborate on that
yeah so they kind of like hit it in
there they didn't really touch on it but
uh snuck in there you you have a bit
where you're
in first person and you're in the back
of a concert hall
and then they show like you go out on
stage
and you have johnny's silver hand
and i was like oh this is a scene where
you're playing as
johnny in a samurai concert
so i think what it probably is is it's
like a brain dance where you're you're
reliving one of like johnny's memories
from like the 2020s where uh back when
samurai was still
around and so i think they're gonna have
because johnny's supposed to be like a
really major character in the game
like apparently keanu has like the most
speaking lines next to v
so he's like in the game quite a bit and
i think i think they're gonna do a lot
of diving into johnny's backstory so
they're gonna have these moments where
maybe
you get to experience scenes through
through johnny's eyes
and i i mean you get to play as virtual
keanu reeves that sounds pretty cool
timor what did you think of that whole
samurai
refused mini dock they showed off
personally i love i love the fact that
even when they're doing like
european death metal style to be like
future or like rock and roll
like uh anarchist you know punk rock
they still are so european that their
like studio looks like it was
constructed in ikea
and everyone's really polite and like
they do they're screaming into the mic
and then turning to the camera and like
you know how american musicians are like
they're like
long-haired tattoos all over or whatever
and they
they lean into the stereotype of like
punk rock these guys are like no we're
just like
we're just clean cut europeans would
that like to do some death metal
or punk rock i love that like the whole
documentary part of it had some like
spinal tap vibes to it like where he's
like screaming into the mic and then
there's a thumbs up into the camera as
if like yep did it did some music
um but i liked where the the actual
sound stuff was oh the the
soundtrack stuff is going um and also
like the the stuff that uh
jean-luc pointed out like what i'm
interested in seeing
is like the brain down stuff that we did
in our gameplay demo was like a
voluntary thing that v did
um as part of the heist like you kind of
meet up with a character and
she walks you through the brain dance
and then you do one here and there and
then you actually go into
um into the scenario and and play
it plays out in the same way but i'm
wondering if like the
the stuff with the brain dance and and
johnny silverhand's
um uh part in it is a little more forced
because he basically
you know it's implied that he sets up
shop in your body and in your mind
so is that something where you don't
really have influence over when that
happens like
is is it just him like uh is it like an
intrusive thought or is it like johnny
silverhand
feeding you information and if that is
the case like
what is the potential for him to be an
unreliable narrator
or like a a kind of someone who's going
to betray you in the end by feeding you
the information that you need to know
like what are his motivations here what
does he want to have and how can he
manipulate his own memories
and you experiencing his memories to get
what he wants
um so there's a lot of like mileage in
that and from a narrative perspective
yeah i mean uh oh sorry
go ahead john nick oh i was just gonna
say that they have in the past
actually said that your your
motivations and johnny's motivations
don't have to be aligned and that
there is that potential for you to
become like
not not necessarily antagonist but for
for you to kind of like split off or or
be working against each other
so i'm yeah i'm super curious about the
idea of like
the end of the game could have this huge
variation where like
maybe the end of the game could be this
like dramatic showdown between
you and and johnny in your head that
would be
oh that would be so cool i want that
i i'm still like so into the idea of
just having
keanu reeves in my head but
can you can you imagine if it's like
out there you know the modern day
gaming's version of like the wood you
kindly from bioshock but it's keanu
reeves saying
would you kindly in like you know that
could be amazing
um so another big announcement well uh
something that's available right now is
a new song by samurai or refuse is
released on spotify right now it's
called the like supreme
uh like i said like i said in the
pre-show there's already three or four
other songs available
that you can listen to and i'm excited
to listen to that after this
uh but i think the big the last thing
they really showed off were the weapons
and they talked a lot about the weapons
um some of this stuff we already knew
but we'll kind of
dig into it once again uh and let's just
start with
weapon customization what were three of
the big things they kind of talked about
when it came to weapon customization
john luke do you want to take this one
sure yeah so with weapon customization i
mean it seems like
they're kind of doing the typical video
game like i don't know if it's full on
crafting but you can
you know tweak your scopes and and stuff
like that
um which yeah i mean like that's that's
exciting that's i don't know it's pretty
standard
video game fair i kind of expected that
i'm i'm very curious
in sort of like the variations of the
type of weapons
they they show like a little bit of some
of like the different powers that you
use
um or the different like tweaks to them
um like uh you you there
there's the uh the scatter shot like a
shotgun that um like can bounce off the
ground and stuff like that i
i want to see more of that stuff like i
hope there's i hope there's some that
they're saving
because i think the stuff they showed
looks cool but i want i want it to get
weirder if that makes sense
yeah totally uh one thing uh when i
played
when i played the demo a couple months
ago is we didn't really get to mess
around with attachments but we did get
to mod our weapons
and it definitely like like one thing
they mentioned is how it can actually
like really change the way a gun feels
and that's something that i didn't
notice
but uh probably because it was early but
that is definitely an aspect like
different guns have different
slots for soft software mods that you
can plug in kind of like
in the witcher 3 right where you can uh
if i remember correctly you can equip
like different i forget exactly what
they're called but basically you can
give like passive effects to your swords
and stuff depending on
uh oh man i feel what they're called
like the jewels or whatever you'd equip
uh right but uh tomorrow considering you
played it and you got to mess around
with weapons and stuff did you
notice any uh were you able to mess
around with attachments or sophomore
mods at all
i i kind of like uh i messed around with
some of the
um kind of basic attachment stuff which
was like
scopes and that kind of business and it
looked like
it was quite versatile which i really
really appreciated i think i had
a pistol which was silenced but also a
scope on it um which meant i could like
hide behind cover and take out enemies
from afar
and kind of manipulate walking patterns
and kind of enemy movement
from a distance to kind of sneak around
um
that was when i was actually getting
involved in combat um
so for the stuff that he showed like the
main thing that i'm
super happy that they talked about um
like going back to
metal gear solid five which is probably
the greatest stuff game of all time in
my opinion
what i love about that game and it's
something that i wish that more games
did was
um it provides non-lethal options
for lethal weapons so you could take an
assault rifle into a mission but it
would be
all non-lethal rounds and tranq rounds
and stuff like that
so you never feel cut out of gameplay so
watching most of this they were talking
about the guns and i was kind of tuning
out because i was like i'm probably none
of this is probably gonna work for me
because
i prefer to you know do non-lethal stuff
and then right towards the end they
mentioned you do get the option for
non-lethal rounds
there wasn't a lot of reflection on that
or elaboration so i'm not sure if that's
for
all the guns just the gun that they were
specifically talking about does it just
does it extend to like the you know the
high frequency blade or the cyberware
that kind of stuff are there non-lethal
options for that
but who knows we'll find out but at
least i'm i appreciate the fact that
they have thought about people who might
take the non-lethal approach
i mean i don't mind shooting and doing
like virtual
uh killing but i just find more of a
challenge uh in kind of figuring out
non-lethal ways to do it and i'm glad
that they're not
locking me out of all the cool weapons
because that would be a shame
it's far too many games where it's like
oh you pick non-lethal so that means you
get to use this pistol for the rest of
your entire 70-hour campaign in this
game
um but yeah i couple that with like some
of the attachments i hope it still works
i'd love the
ability to shoot a non-lethal round
through a wall to incapacitate an
unsuspecting enemy or like a long-range
sniper rifle
like that it's a tranquilizer dart like
you know most nagan from like mj3 or
like
anna from you know um overwatch or
something like that
i'm excited i hope that the non-lethal
stuff is
as comprehensive and as like baked into
the entire combat experience as
the lethal stuff is john luke did you
have something you wanted to add to that
oh i just my favorite thing was the
cyberware
the the potential of like so they showed
a couple options they showed the blades
which we've seen before and they showed
um the like gorilla arms where you can
like pull
um like giant heavy guns out of like
turrets that you normally can't use or
beat people up and
they show the cannon i don't know if
this will be possible but i would
love to know if you could play the
entire game just using
cyberware and no guns like can i just
have all my weapons be
my hands and like that's how i play the
entire game
i don't i get the feeling that's
probably not the case like i don't know
if um
they're those are like versatile enough
to actually be able to get through the
whole game that way but i would love to
be able to do a play through where it's
like i don't use guns i just use my
my cyber hands and like they morph into
different things
yeah that's actually uh an interesting
thing to bring up when i play the demo i
actually asked
one of the developers like because in
cyberpunk 2020 there's something called
what's called i think it's called like
cyberpsychosis or something and it's if
you
are too cybered up basically your
character goes crazy because there's no
body left really uh and i asked if
that's something you can do
in the game and he said no because the
the character v
uh like that character knows not to do
that
so you are unable to do that uh
but that being said there's still like a
ton of
like slots you can equip cybernetic
weapons to
uh or cybernetic augmentations to so
yeah to your point i'm kind of curious
to see how much you can just like equip
weapons to that like i wonder if i can
get like eyes that
shoot lasers or something like that you
know something wild
um they also showed off the different
weapon types and a lot of these weapon
types they've kind of talked about or
we've seen but they
formally kind of went through them
there's smart weapons tech weapons power
weapons and melee weapons
and melee weapons is something i want to
talk a little bit more about uh
particularly in your case tomorrow
are there any melee weapons that you
think could go along with this
uh pacifist run you plan on doing
because a lot of the weapons once again
they showed are just like
katanas and and like i was using a lead
pipe like is there even a
non-lethal weapon that you can think of
that would help you out
i'd love for them to make the katana
work in a non-lethal capacity i don't
think it's impossible like we have stun
guns
in most games that are like you know
easily to
use to kind of incapacitate people um i
think if they had like dull blade but
with like a passes of current
when you hit an enemy um that could be a
way to make it work or even like
i'd love the idea of bringing in um
the kind of like uh batman arkham
origins style
uh gauntlets that have uh a current
running through it that when you punch
someone in knocks them out or something
like that um
melee wise i i would hope that there's
something built into the cyberware that
is
non-lethal that isn't like specifically
just you're gonna shred
everyone um mainly because that would
mean i'm not able to use cyberware
um too much uh i mean obviously if i
decide i want to
descend into some chaos and just use it
i can but i try and avoid it as much as
possible
but i hope there is an option for that i
want to be able to
fire tranquilizer darts out my fingers
like this like
finger gun style that would be great um
if i can do that that would be stick
but i will take like a katana or even
like a short
short sword or like a dagger i love the
idea of dagger
you know everyone who watches naruto and
we'll know asumas
is knuckle duster blade which has a like
you can extend with chakra
and just remove the chakra put in uh
electricity electro electric current and
you're in business you can have that all
for free sleepy project red
crib from naruto no you what you need to
do tomorrow is just
get the mantis blades and just take
their legs off that's it
that's not people they can't follow you
you're good uh
so the one of the last notes i have here
that i didn't want to talk about is
something that i kind of got glimpses of
when i played the demo
but weapon rarities they said they range
from common uncommon rare
uh to legendary i believe
uh that's something that was also in the
witcher to an extent
right there was like common uncommon i
think relic was like one of the toughest
ones to find
um but one thing interesting they
mentioned was how
a lot of these legendary weapons are
tied to different quests so you'll have
to make
difficult decisions in order to get
legendary weapons uh john luke just to
toss it to you i was curious kind of
like what you
think about you know the this whole
weapon tier
loot system knowing that you know you
play a lot of destiny so
oh sure yeah uh yeah i mean i'm into it
i
i love the idea of tying it to quest
as opposed to like i'm glad the game
doesn't seem like it has like a grinding
system or anything like
like a weapon rarity in terms of like i
got to keep looting these chests and
hopefully i get a legendary like if
they're all tied to quests i think
that's the that's the smart way to do it
that's the game's strength
i'm hoping the legendary weapons are
where like
the weird stuff comes into play that i
was kind of talking about like you know
they've shown like you know the smart
bullets and the ricocheting i'm like
yeah that's all cool but i want to see
some like really weird out there stuff
so i'm hoping
each each legendary weapon feels like
really unique
and interesting as opposed to just it's
got the best stats
i'd be a little disappointed if it was
just that um so i'm hoping i'm hoping we
get to see some like
unique unique guns yeah based on what
they said it sounds like they plan on
doing some unique things with these
legendary weapons
uh but you know when the game comes out
november 19th
i'm sure we'll have some guides about
where to get the coolest or best
legendary weapons
but with that is there any last minute
stuff you guys want to bring up that we
may have seen
or uh that you want to touch on tomorrow
do you want to
anything um i think we're still trying
to figure out whether we'll get to hear
keanu reeve sing
i think we settled upon no which is a
shame
but i would love it if we got to see and
hear keanu reeves sing
and now that you between jake and john
luke you've mentioned it like i
really want to see ronda jones give me a
quest
i hope i hope that they i hope that
they've gone the extra mile to like put
them in the game
in the same way that they you know you
know they've got them on board so please
i hope they're in there
give us give us uh some wrap up musical
artists to get quests from
jean-luc anything anything on your end
that stood out that you want to touch on
before we wrap this up i
i just want to see more johnny
silverhand at this point i think that's
the big thing everyone wants to see not
just because it's keanu but because i
think johnny
is like to me the most interesting
uh part of the story so far like you
know what exactly his motivations are
how that's going to play in how do you
interact with him like
is it is it you know do you get to have
like full-on conversations with him
anytime you want is it like the um uh to
make another batman comparison batman
arkham knight
where like is he like the joker where he
just kind of like randomly shows up and
like quips at you for like a second and
then leaves like i want to see
how that that narrative plays out
throughout the game
and and to what level can you can you
interact with johnny
and like you know can you can he become
the antagonist
like can you have these like you know is
it like a tyler durden situation right
where like
he he goes too far and then you you have
to stop him like he took control of your
body
and like did something terrible and then
you have to you have to stop johnny i'm
so i'm so curious
like i think that's the most interesting
part of the game yeah
totally i i think for me the big thing
that i really want to know more about
are the
how the relationships are going to work
in this game because that's something
that they talked about
years ago about how like cyberpunk
features like very
adult relationships and and i'm curious
to see what they do with that because
that's something we haven't
really heard about and based on what
they said it sounds like they're not
they're not they're very like non-linear
and how they play out so i'm excited to
see
where exactly they go with that just in
terms even in terms of like
you know like can i go hang out with
jackie and go
go play pool or something like i'm
thinking like gta 4 style hanging out
where he's calling me up from being like
hey let's go let's go get drunk or
something like that and
that's something i'm super curious about
because games typically don't handle
that
super well unless they're designed for
that kind of unless they're designed
with those mechanics in mind
so i'm super curious to see how all that
stuff plays out
uh but with that that is uh that was the
cyberpunk
night wire um make sure to tune in to
gamespot
gamespot when this game comes out
november 19th we're gonna have a ton of
stuff but leading up until then john
luke and i are doing a lore series
uh we already have two videos up already
one is about the history of night city
and then the other is all about johnny
silverhand in his past so make sure to
check that out
and we'll have a new episode going up on
saturday uh which is all about arasaka
and you won't want to miss it but with
that we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you